so now we wrote down the momentum of the
system of our rocket at time T and the
momentum the system of the rocket at
time T plus delta-t
let's make some simplifications in our
notation just to make our calculations a
little more easy to read so the first
thing we want to do is we want to say
that the mass of the rocket at time T
this is the mass of the rocket plus the
mass of the fuel in the rocket at time T
we're just going to denote that by M R
and keep in mind that when you write the
mass at time T plus delta-t will write
that as the mass at time t plus delta mr
this is precisely how you define a
differential even if this quantity is
pot is negative you always write the
difference M of R of T plus Delta t
minus M of RT equal to Delta M R that's
how we write a differential Delta mass
of the rocket so the mass of the rocket
at time T looks simpler M of R plus
Delta M R so those are two ways of
simplifying our expressions for the
terms that are appearing here and there
now the next thing was recall from our
mass conservation that we had the
condition that Delta M fuel was equal to
minus Delta M rocket so now we'll take
those two simplifications and now we'll
write down our system momentum at time T
that's very simple
M R B of R at time T and we'll now write
the momentum at time T plus delta T well
we have the first piece which is M R
plus Delta M R times the velocity of the
rocket at time T plus delta T now be
careful here because we're going to use
our conservation of mass condition to
replace Delta M fuel with minus Delta M
rocket
we'll use our expression for the
velocity of fuel in the ground frame of
the rocket so we have minus Delta M
rocket times the velocity u plus B of R
of T plus delta T and this
simplification will write equations one
and equation two will enable us to apply
the momentum principle in a very
transparent way and that's what we'll do
next